you saw that orlando brown had been
traded by the ravens to one of their top
rivals in the conference
yeah like wow like whoa like i mean i
think the first thing i just was more
it was all chiefs related for me at
first to just go
i mean what a bold move the chiefs the
the one thing i just you know
they're one of those teams again every
year it's just like
here you go there's the pot we're all in
we're all in 2021 it's super bowl or
bust we don't give a damn about anything
else
and that's what i love i mean i love it
from that standpoint
i love it from the standpoint of like of
course
you protect your baby god jesus
quarterback
patrick mahomes in all cases like what
we got to do in the super bowl super
bowl right well they learn their lesson
they because really if he's protected
they have a chance in every game no
matter who they play
for the next five years it just doesn't
matter we've seen that
when he has protection and can dance
around it doesn't matter who it is
he can make it happen and that's where i
give the chiefs like a ton of credit
yeah they need to do it because the best
player in their league is their quarter
is their quarterback
and they're in the window and
mike the other thing i love about it
like you and i talk about it all the
time
is you know that they're just they're
just go they go all in and go no we have
an elite unit
we're going all in on our offense it's
going to be so damn
awesome and we're going to dictate your
offense and defensive play
because our offense is so awesome we're
going to dictate the game with that side
of the ball
and that's where i love the chiefs in
this move this is the most
amazing package of incompletions in the
history of the national football i think
it is amazing
what patrick mahomes tried to do
single-handedly
guys dropping passes guys almost made
office plays
and it's all coming from the fact that
he was running for his life all game
long because they didn't have their
starting tackles
they didn't do anything to help the
tackles they
had it was five on however many the
buccaneers were sending
and uh now orlando brown on one bad foot
presumably the left tackle
yeah on one bad foot and now they've
added
joe tooney one of the best guards in
football
they got a better center in in blyth uh
austin blyth from the los angeles rams
you know we got duvernay tardif back
kyle long there he goes i mean you look
at this off
and they got other guys you know they
got lucas nang who uh niang i'm probably
butchering his name and i don't mean to
out of tcu who they drafted two years
ago in the draft
who i know they like there's other
players they got so they went from
going whoa this is a really thin
offensive line to you go
whoa this is one of the better offensive
lines in football
and they have some depth and versatility
to it so
that's a strong unit right there i mean
that really is i i
that's veach and andy reid you know
really doing a great job
of addressing a problem in the off
season and
i mean really didn't exhaust all their
expenses to do it and do those type of
things i think it was a
a no-brainer awesome trade for a guy in
orlando brown who's a franchise
left tackle type of player mike i can
only imagine that the ravens traded him
to the chiefs as
an almost absolute last resort
any other team in the league yeah i
thought maybe the vikings would be the
team
that would end up potentially with
orlando brown junior with some sort of a
flip-flop in round one or something like
that but
to go to the chiefs i mean that's that's
a half click away from trading them to
the steelers for crying out loud that's
what surprised me
you're you're making one of your top
rivals better the team
that your quarterback has called your
kryptonite
you've you've given them another chunk
of kryptonite that they can use against
you
right when when they come to town during
the regular season in 2021 and when you
potentially face them in the postseason
right and and kryptonite to
the fact like they can't get to my homes
when they play them
and now they got they gave them a
mountain a mountain for a left tackle
in orlando brown junior so it is it is
interesting and mike i i mean i think
you're right i got to think
that they were probably exhausting all
options to just go
wait like yeah we want to trade you oh
wait the chiefs have a good offer
anybody else out there anybody else out
there any other offers please please
please oh the chiefs have a good offer
anybody please make an offer
but i think they realized that this guy
was gone after next year
are gonna cause issues and yeah they got
a good offer from the chiefs and so be
it
and the the ravens you know them they
got they still got a lot of good
offensive linemen
and they'll find somebody here in the
draft to improve that part of their
team i'm not worried about them really
yeah and
and you're right it was clear he didn't
want to be there so you got to ask
yourself what are you going to do we're
going to kick the can for a year and
then he leaves us a free age and then we
finally get a compensatory draft pick
another year after that or do we take
what we can get now
and they surely have an idea of what
they're going to do now they got 27
and 31. interesting to see whether they
maybe package those and try to move up
right right or it's just it's two
lottery tickets they get to use at the
bottom of round one
and and there's no way they do that and
take on that pick
if they're not damn confident they're
gonna get a really good player in that
spot
you don't do it especially not to the
chiefs no i i know so there must be guys
on the board there that
they're very happy with nonetheless yeah
i mean hey listen maybe they addressed
they could address an offensive lineman
with one of those two picks
certainly you know there's no doubt
about that we know they need edge guys
right that would be another thing i
would be looking at they've lost judon
and and you know uh our guys
smith uh zadaria smith up in green bay
the last few years in free agency
you know i would think they're looking
for that type of guy there towards the
end of the first round and i would think
there's some guys on the
on the board you know that that fit that
mold so that would be interesting to
to see uh i mean maybe maybe they get
the the rusal kid from miami who
collects campbell just stuck up for
and everything like that i mean he's a
guy that i think could certainly see
sitting there
at the end of the first round mike as
far as a big defensive end who could
help out their
their defensive line for sure and and
that
would be awesome if gregory rousseau
right
ends up falling to the ravens and they
unite him with calais campbell campbell
has been such a champion for rousseau
all these questions about is he going to
go round one
when the agent comes out and says there
are multiple teams that have said
they're going to take him in round one
unless he's already told the player he's
lying
just to try to pump up his market the
age good agents know
they know because and the teams have a
reason to let them know because there's
a broader relationship where you
negotiate contracts so
that'd be something if ravens end up
being the team to take him
at number 27. uh and uh
they definitely they well now they have
a need at right tackle
and they may that's the other side of
this they they're planning to sign
alejandro villanueva
from the steelers right after the draft
they want to play that
compensatory draft pick game right the
window closes after the draft
on any of those unrestricted free agent
signings
counting toward the compensatory draft
pick formula and few teams master that
formula like the ravens
so that's how they presumably are going
to replace orlando brown jr
alejandro villanueva moves left side to
right side and moves
steelers to ravens yeah no i mean i
think that's
that's probably the plan we hear right
they were talking to dennis kelly i
believe
too this past weekend or he was in the
building for a visit
so they have the ravens have a plan set
forth here
uh as far as life for after orlando
brown jr
and even with that you know again like
you said ronnie staley was hurt last
year he'll be back
they got zeitler you know they got a lot
of other guys that played a lot
on their offensive line last year
because of their injuries they were
mixed and matched so
they have bodies here this is not like
oh no what are the ravens gonna do
they're decimated at offensive line now
they're they're a smart football team
their offensive line is one of the keys
to their
their keys to success but yeah i would
say that one of those right tackles is
getting signed here in the next few days
and i wouldn't be shocked if we
we saw somebody get drafted too for
baltimore
just another layer of intrigue for when
the ravens and the chiefs get together
in the regular season in baltimore
orlando brown jr will be
back in town and he and others will be
protecting patrick mahomes and
letting him run around not for his life
but because he chooses to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports